even the most serious Pursuits for
example the pursuit of science is a form
of Play It's the highest form of play
right because in the same way that you
try to solve a 1 000 piece puzzle by
putting the pieces together well what is
science it's it's drawing links between
a whole bunch of variables that
heretofore you didn't know were linked
together so the whole Endeavor of
science is a form of or geostic higher
order play right
[Music]
hello everyone watching and listening
today I'm speaking with my friend Dr Gad
sad professor at Concordia University
researcher podcaster
an author of the new book The sad truth
about happiness eight secrets for
leading the good life
I'm here with my friend today Dr gadsad
we've met a number of times I gotta say
um Dr Saad was one of the first
and really one of the few academics who
supported me right at the beginning when
I was embroiled in the first round of
controversy that enveloped me or that I
stirred up you know or that our idiot
government stirred up which is more
accurate uh description of the whole
event gag was one of the first people
who had the uh
courage or the or the uh hutzpah I guess
that's the word to to interview me and
and to discuss my situation with me and
you know he played that very very
straight and I don't think it was
obvious to him at all at that point when
he took that risk you know he didn't
know anything about me really he could
have easily decided like so many people
did that I was just fundamentally
reprehensible
and uh you know stayed on the safe side
of the fence but I don't really think
that's the sort of person he is and I
think that's become more and more
evident over the ensuing uh months and
years and so I want to thank you again
for that you know it was a brave moment
one of the things I learned you know in
the last six or seven years is that
um courage is a very very rare virtue
much rarer than I even thought you know
I'd studied
um totalitarian States for a long time
and I knew that people were easily led
into a state of pathological science
silence but I didn't understand how
rapidly that could occur and how few
people even in a free Society with a
long history of Freedom would be loath
to speak
um and and how rapidly that could occur
you know and then you do see people who
stand up and say things that might get
them in trouble and some of them are
just people who
are unwise right and who are willing to
impulsively say what
comes to mind and then there are other
people and they're much rare
who are thoughtful and who carefully
considered what they have to say and are
willing to say it anyways and you fell
into that camp right away and you've
been pursuing that for a good long time
and you know also with a sense of humor
which is I think a sign of Mastery by
the way you know you just wrote a book
called The sad truth about happiness
that's coming out July 25th I believe
and you know it is the case that I think
you're a credible Observer on that front
because you have this playful aspect
that you it doesn't disappear even when
you're dealing with serious topics at
some risk to yourself and so I think
that makes you a credible Observer on
that front and anyways I'm done
complimenting you so uh you could you
could say one or two comments about how
how might how good my tan looks after
spending two weeks in Portugal it is it
is very impressive I must say you're
you're positively glowing sir and so now
anything else is there anything else I
need to add to that no I'm just uh it's
it's been a delight we'll finish with
the reciprocal complement compliments
but it's been a a delight forging uh
friendship with you as you said I think
we we got to know each other about seven
years ago and uh you know of the
ecosystem that we both navigate in
regrettably many people turn out to be
cowards and you're certainly not one who
exhibits any cowardice and so in that
sense we are truly sympatico and it's a
it's a pleasure and honor to be your
friend yeah well and we we have areas of
mutual interest as well you know I'm
I've been interested in
psychology of Entrepreneurship and of of
managerial and administrative ability
for that matter I spent a lot of time
studying that and also very interested
in evolutionary psychology and biology
and so we have those overlaps which is
quite interesting professionally and so
um I thought that's part of where we can
go today as well as talking about your
book let's start with your last book The
parasitic mind when was that published
Gad
so it came out right in the midst of
covert October 2020 was the hardcover
and then a year later in October 2021
the paperback came out yeah and how did
it do and how is it doing
well it's always difficult to be excited
about how well it's done when you're
speaking to someone who sold 20 12
million copies of his last book so if we
don't use you as a benchmark then I
think it did remarkably well so I'm very
happy with it but as I often tell my
wife it's done incredibly well but not
enough to give me an exit strategy out
of communist Quebec so it's done well
but maybe I'm saying this in front of a
guys behind the line who are all proud
to be quebecers I love Quebec
but I'm not very happy about uh as you
might agree with the sort of Socialist
Communist ethos here I'm not a fan of
the cold weather so hopefully the next
book will offer me the at least the
option of having an exit strategy if I
choose to implement it yeah well the
university that you happen to inhabit
also has a very pronounced left-wing
tilt to put it mildly they do yes that's
for sure it's amazing that you've been
able to survive there at all so do you
want to just familiarize people with the
thesis of the parasitic mind and sure
and then we'll turn to your new book and
then we'll talk a little bit more about
evolutionary biology and psychology I
think that sounds like a great plan uh
so my last book what I was trying to do
is argue that in the same way that all
sorts of animals can be parasitized by
neuroparasites actual parasites that can
go into an animal's brain altering Its
Behavior to suit its reproductive
interests I argue that human beings can
be parasitized by another class of
pathogens
called idea pathogens and so these
ideological parasites can then cause us
to take positions that are truly
maladaptive and so what I do in the book
is I first describe many of these idea
pathogens postmodernism social
constructivism biophobia uh cultural
relativism and a slew of other such
parasites all of which were regrettably
spawned in the University ecosystem
because as I to sort of borrow from
George Orwell it takes intellectuals to
come up with some of the dumbest ideas
and so then what I do is I trace the uh
the spawning of these brain parasites
and then I offer uh hopefully an
effective mind vaccine against these
parasitic ideas so that's the general
thesis okay okay so let me delve into
that a little bit there there's a few
things that I'd like to clarify on that
front get your opinion about so the
first is is that you could imagine
something approximating a darwinian race
between sets of ideas
for memorability and communicability
right so for an idea to spread it
obviously has to be memorable which
means it has to be adapted to the
structure of human memory and there's a
biological element to that but it also
has to be charismatic enough so that the
people who remember it will also
communicate it and so stories seem to
fit into that category quite well we we
seem to be very fond of stories so you
could imagine that there's a competition
between sets of ideas and it's sort of a
detached competition in some ways it's
it's the free darwinian play of ideas
that could occupy our cognitive space
both in terms of memory and on the
communicative front and so you could
think about those ideas that come to the
top of that as either having some
practical function or as actually
serving as in some ways that of genuine
as genuine parasites in the cognitive
space but then there's another element
to this too and I want to know what you
think about this so you know I've been
delving into the
since about 2016
psychologists have finally in their
wisdom determined that there is such a
thing as left-wing authoritarianism
and so that would be a web of ideas that
are
correlated in in that if you have one
you're likely to have the others you can
identify that said I did some of the
work on that early work on that with one
of my students Christine Brophy we found
a set of progressive ideas and then a
set of totalitarian leftist ideas that
combined the progressive ethos with the
willingness to use fear and compulsion
and force to implement them okay and so
we found we found the following
predictors because we were curious is do
this does this system of ideas exist or
is it just a right wing you know
conspiracy delusion and the answer is
there's clearly a set of coherent
statistically coherent left-wing ideas
that
are allied with the willingness to use
compulsion and force and we found
four major predictors of the proclivity
to have that idea set and the first
predictor and it was a walloping
predictor negative 0.45 if I remember
correctly verbal intelligence and pl and
left-wing authoritarianism correlated
more highly than verbal intelligence and
and academic performance right a
stunning correlation so when you ask
yourself you know how P how can people
be Daft enough to accept this relatively
reductionistic and simple-minded view of
the world everything is about power one
of the answers to that is well they're
not very verbally sophisticated okay the
second best predictor was being female
the third best predictor was having a
feminine temperament
independent of being female right and
the fourth best predictor was
um having ever taken even one explicitly
politically correct
higher education course
so now
since then
other people have developed analogous
models of left-wing authoritarianism and
looked for other predictors and
one of the most interesting predictors
that has emerged is there's a very
powerful relationship between the dark
tetrad personality characteristics
including malignant narcissism and the
proclivity to hold left-wing
authoritarian views in fact the
correlation between malignant narcissism
and
left-wing authoritarianism is 0.6
which is so high that you could make the
case because the scales are somewhat
unreliable you could make the case that
they're not distinguishable on the
measurement front Okay I know this is a
long-winded question but I want to
specify it exactly all right so
the dark tetrad personality types they
have subclined they show subclinical
characteristics of psychopaths and
psychopaths are predatory parasites
and so so we could imagine there's two
forms of parasitism going on here
there's there's the darwinian
competition between idea sets for
memorability and communicability but
then there's the proclivity for people
who occupy the parasitical niche in the
human ecosystem and that would
essentially be Psychopaths to utilize
ideas like the parasitical idea sets
that you described for their own truly
parasitical purposes and then I want to
decorate that with one more thing so you
correct me if you're wrong here I think
this is actually
especially because of the emerging
virtualization of the world I actually
think that there's an existential threat
here because
parasitism is an unbelievably deep
problem right sex itself evolved to foil
parasites and there's always been
parasitical people criminals and the
like and the most parasitical of those
are the Psychopaths and we've evolved
mechanisms to keep the parasitical
Predators under control a lot of them
involve physical force and all of our
evolved mechanisms for dampening down
the parasite the predatory parasites
none of them work online and so I think
our whole culture is enabling the
predatory psychopath on the criminal
front and on the sub-criminal front
right 35 percent of net traffic is
pornographic online crime is rampant and
then you have all the demon troll types
you know who are polluting the political
discourse and there's data on them too
so if you're an online troll you're much
more likely to show all the dark tetrad
traits narcissism and machiavellianism
psychopathy and to top it all off sadism
so so please have out that set of ideas
there's a lot of good stuff that you put
in there so I'll try to take a couple of
threads number one your your first point
about you know the the battle between
the arena ideas there's actually a whole
field called evolutionary epistemology
that exactly speaks to what you're
saying that idea so think back of
Richard Dawkins uh when he introduced
the concept of the meme in his 1976 book
The Selfish Gene so there was a whole
field that unfortunately hasn't lived up
to its promise called memetic theory
that exactly tries to model what you
said which is there's a bunch of ideas
floating around and what is the
darwinian mechanism
that allows some ideas to be selected
versus others that fail now in in my
book and then I'll come in a second to
some of the predictors that you spoke
about in terms of left-wing
authoritarianism uh in my book I
basically argue that what uh what is
common to all of these parasitic ideas
is they wish to be free
from the pesky shackles of reality right
so post-modernism as we we've both
commented on is the ultimate granddaddy
of all parasitic ideas because it
basically frees us from you know the
pesky shackles of objective reality
because it purports that there are there
is no objective Truth
transgenderism uh frees me from the
pesky reality of my genitalia social
constructivism frees me from the idea
that there might be innate biological
differences between people so it really
stems originally from the noble notion
of seeking to maximize empathy right uh
so the I so the idea starts off as a
noble idea but then it metamorphosizes
into complete garbage in the pursuit of
that empathy to the detriment of truth
right so that's number one number two
regarding your predictors uh I actually
am familiar with the study that you
mentioned I think it was a thesis that
you supervised correct yeah that's right
right yeah so we actually looked uh so
I'm I'm actually working right now with
a graduate student myself where we're
looking and we've actually looked at the
thesis that you supervised with your
student we're looking at another set of
predictors that might interest you
Jordan and specifically we're looking at
morphological predictors of ideological
positions that people take now that's
uniquely interesting because you might
otherwise not think that your morphology
might be linked to the ideological
positions that you take but it turns out
and I discussed this in the parasitic
mind that for example
your likelihood of supporting military
interventionism is correlated to your
upper body strength not surprisingly so
now I'm talking about male subjects male
subjects who are stronger are more
likely to support military
interventionism uh Stronger men are more
likely to be against
egalitarianism I mean enforced
egalitarianism right yeah taking from
one and so that to me is uniquely
interesting because you can look at
symmetry so there's exactly I don't know
if you guys know this but there's a
paper that was published two months ago
something like that looking at
uh they they used facial averaging of
activist Types on the left and then
conservative types you saw that so the
conservatives well I was I was Obsession
I saw that paper because because they're
kind of they're they're stealing some of
our thunder right you might remember in
the uh in the parasitic mind although I
remember I think I first proposed this
Theory to you in our first conversation
when you came on my show remember I
talked about
male social justice Warriors as sneaky
[__] actual term right yeah yeah well
sneaky [__] is actually not a term
that I came up with to be profane it's
actually a Zoological term that captures
uh in nature the the idea of kleptogamy
where you're trying to steal mating
opportunities so for example let's say
you have a type of fish where there are
two phenotypes of a male you know of a
male there's the dominant physically
imposing male and then there's a whole
bunch of other males that actually
pretend to be females so that they can
sneak by the dominant males and then
have a surreptitious coupling
opportunity with the females and that
became known as the sneaky [__] mating
strategy and so in the in the parasitic
mind I argue that male social justice
Warriors are
instantiating a form of sneaky [__]
strategy right look look I'm I'm you
know I'm very sensitive I hug trees I
cry when I watch Bridget Jones Diary see
I'm not you don't have anything to be
afraid of and then hopefully that can
allow me to have access to some willing
and available females so do you know so
you know their literature on orangutans
so you know there's two types of male
well there's two forms of male orangutan
in any given
um Eco like what would you say roughly
tribal uh uh low Eco local ecology so
there's one form of male develops he's
like the quarterback orangutan he gets
so big he can't even really be arboreal
he has the huge fat pads around his face
that make him round it makes his face
round he's very physically powerful and
the females come to him to mate but then
there are other male orangutans in the
same area that for a long time
anthropologists primatologists thought
were juveniles but it turns out they're
not juveniles they're males who don't
undergo the complete transformation into
the the non-non arboreal male and they
use exactly The Mating strategy that you
described right so there's exactly yeah
yeah yeah yeah well that's why I was so
I'm I'm always amazed that people get so
uh triggered by your Lobster analogy
because the whole field of comparative
psychology operates on the premise that
we could learn a lot about human
cognition by studying our animal cousins
I mean right I mean that's the whole
premise behind the tree of life so I
don't really see why someone would be so
triggered by the fact that you use the
the dominance hierarchies of lobsters to
then make certain points about human
society
there's a whole field called comparative
psychology that does that so to me the
people who are coming after you uh for
those kinds of uh analogies between us
and other animals uh are simply
displaying their ignorance right yeah
well they're mad at me because if
lobsters have hierarchies it's pretty
hard to blame hierarchy on capitalism
you know because we haven't discovered a
sub-genus of capitalist Lobster yet and
Strikes me as highly unlikely that we
will
but let me ask you this I mean we're
going off sort of our but I mean
conversations are organic so this might
be a good opportunity to talk about this
why do you think
that you uh trigger a lot more animus
than I do because one could argue that I
actually On Any Given Tuesday morning
will tweet as many if not more things
that are quite quote controversial and
yet somehow I now obviously your
platform is larger than mine but even if
we correct for that even if we do it per
capita there seems to be something and
by the way I've been asked that many
times when I appear on shows because
people know that we're friends and
they'll ask me you know how come you
don't get so let me turn it to you since
we're now chatting do you have a theory
as to why you are such a polarizing
figure whereas
you know I might one can argue I take
positions you know I mean I'll criticize
Islam a lot more forcefully yeah and yet
somehow I don't trigger as much animus
what what do you what do you think is
the drama maybe I annoyed people on more
fronts simultaneously than you did
partly well can so what happened this is
a possible explanation you know when
when things first blew up around me in
I already had 200 hours of lectures on
YouTube
and so you know I was pilloried as a
right-wing demon essentially by the
sorts of people that we're discussing
who like to do that sort of thing to
hide their own character let's say and
then people looked me up online and went
to my YouTube channel and then found you
know this extra hundreds of hours of
content which
demonstrated rather incontrovertibly
that I wasn't the sort of person that I
was being accused of being but also
touched on all sorts of other topics
that people might not have expected a
like in the religious and mythological
domain the psychoanalytic domain and so
I think the fact that I had that
Storehouse of lectures already stored up
when when when the trouble emerged
expanded out my reach in a very dramatic
Manner and that's probably you know as
the first occupier of that position in
some ways because I was an early adopter
of YouTube I know you were too but you
know I think I got there a little faster
than you did and a little a little
broader and so I think that's probably a
fair bit of it you know
um I I wonder also if so like in my
latest book now which I guess we'll talk
about in a second I also engage in
prescriptive remedies you know here are
some steps by which you can increase
your happiness but historically I've
been much more of a descriptive right
right I describe how things are now in
your case by virtue of you also being
having been a clinician by definition
you engage in the ecosystem of
prescriptions a lot more and that I
think triggers people's ire because
you're telling them how to behave and by
doing that you're obviously going to
alienate people whereas I come along and
I say here are the evolutionary reasons
why there are differences between men
and women and I stopped I stopped there
whereas by you taking the prescriptive
jump that probably augments the amount
of animus that you receive what do you
think about it yeah yeah I think I think
that's a reasonable proposition as well
I also think that I think we could
develop that line of uh of hypothesis a
little further too I think that
many of the people who have an animus
against me and almost all those people
are anonymous online trolls by the way
because I never encountered that or
virtually never in my my actual life
quite the contrary I think they're very
very irritated that my simple-minded
prescriptions like take some
responsibility for yourself and don't
play the victim because it's not good
for you or for anyone else I think
they're very very annoyed that first of
all I'm calling them out on their
hypothetically empathic virtue signaling
attempts to escape from all possible
responsibility which is exactly what
they're doing and second they're very
annoyed that the
simple ideas that I've been putting
forward and the simple somewhat
conservative ideas in the end that
they're traditional they're very annoyed
that those work and then they're also
annoyed because I have this very deep
interest in religious issues that also
you know grates on people to some degree
and
um this is something you and I are going
to talk about because it overlaps with
our interest in nomadic ideas because
religious ideas are mimetic ideas for
better or worse you know and and we can
talk about that so
um
you know and then I'm also I think I'm
also probably enabling
to the degree that I'm enabling young
men and and speaking to them about the
virtues of their ambition instead of
dismissing them as pathological you know
patriarchal oppressors that's also very
annoying especially to the types of men
that you're describing who want to sneak
about in the background and pretend to
be virtuous and harmless which is a
pretty damn pathetic way of comporting
yourself in my estimation like I've
watched those kind of men operate in the
protests against me you know and so I
can be surrounded by a mob of pretty
decent screaming harpies and you know
they're annoying as can possibly Be
Imagined but when I look at the men that
are with them they just make my blood
run cold like those are and that's with
my clinical eye those are not good
people you know they're hanging around
those those women who are doing the
harpy thing and they're there as exactly
the kind of parasitical Predator that
you're describing and I can see that and
they are not
they're not the sort of person that you
would want anyone you cared for to come
to to have any association with
whatsoever plus because they have to be
sneaky [__] in your terminology you
know they're bitter and resentful and
they're very likely to want to tear down
anything that approximates true
accomplishment because all those who
have true accomplishment are their
genuine competitors and that's partly
why I think the radical left-wing
authoritarians go after merits so
assiduously is that you know they're
they operate in a completely
non-meritorious basis and it's in their
best interest to present Merit itself as
a falsehood to take out their sexual
competitors
what do you think is the
the main predictor of folks like you and
I who are willing to speak our minds
unencumbered by any shackles of
political correctness and maybe I'll
start by answering it for myself I I
absolutely think it's an indelible part
of your personhood but if I were to give
a more Vivid account of that
I always tell people when they ask me
you know why do you take on these risks
and speak your mind then as you know
Jordan last year I received some pretty
serious death threats and yeah right
right many years and you were very kind
to right away contact names well you get
more Flack on the Jewish front hey so
like I've got more Flack but I would say
I haven't got Flack as serious as some
of what's been levied against you like
I've been fortunate enough to escape
that now because I'm associating with
all the evil Jews at the daily wire I
get some anti-semitic blowback you know
but it hasn't and I've watched a lot of
that online and it's bloody vicious the
the and the anti-semitic parasitical
psychopaths are in a demonic class of
their own they're so they are yes yes
and so you've you so I have been
targeted more frequently but I think
you've been targeted more terrifyingly
that that is true but so but to to to
make the point about uh my unique
situation in terms of why I take the
risks I always argue that at the end of
the night when I put my head on the
pillow uh it is important for me in
order to be able to sleep well at night
to know that I did not modulate my
speech in any way and walk away from
defending the truth if I feel that I
have done that then I would feel
fraudulent and I would feel inauthentic
and one of the probably the highest
ideals that I hold to you know close to
my heart are freedom and truth and so I
speak not because I'm you know trying to
signal that I'm courageous it's because
I don't know how to be anything else so
for example it took me a lot of effort
while I was on my Portugal vacation to
not jump in you know whenever I'd go on
Twitter and see some idiot saying
something my first instinct is to always
come in and you know with some
correction uh it's just an indelible
part of my personhood to speak the truth
and by and then of course in my
forthcoming book as you know we might
talk about I talk about
authenticity and realness as a important
Pathway to happiness right I mean even
you know the ancient Greeks as you know
the delphic maxim know thyself and so I
Know Myself and I know that I can't
modulate my speak so that's my answer
for why I can't hold back and I always
speak the truth is it the same for you
with that exact answer apply to you what
drives you to take the difficult
positions that you take well I think I
think you know they say the uh fear of
God is the beginning of wisdom and I
think that what happened to me in the
course of my studies is at least an
analog of that you know God I I started
studying totalitarian atrocity when I
was 13. you know it's really been an
obsession of mine and it was really a
psychological Obsession rather than a
political one so I was always curious
about the psychology of the perpetrator
right
what sort of person would you have to be
to do those sorts of things or what
Spirit would have to inhabit you you
know and one of the things I learned I
learned a lot of things I learned that
it's easier to be that way than you
think
that you could enjoy it more than you
might
um possibly imagine and that people do
and that
the true grip of the totalitarian state
isn't top down tyranny it's everyone's
willingness to abide by the principles
of the lie and so the more totalitarian
the state the more every single person
in that state is gripped by the lie and
for me that's indistinguishable from
hell and I I think I mean that
practically and also metaphysically and
I learned that
do you know the willingness of people to
utilize their speech instrumentally was
literally the pathway to hell and so
once I actually understood that and and
and understood it in a manner that made
it an incontrovertible Truth for me
everything else became less frightening
by contrast it's like so when I spoke
out against this idiot Bill c-16 back in
2016 which was the Forerunner of much of
the trouble we're seeing now especially
on the gender Insanity front
you know on the one hand there was the
threat of me putting my job on the line
and as it turned out my clinical
practice and of course making myself
unpopular with the government and I
thought that's nowhere near as
frightening to me as the prospect of
losing control of my tongue because I
know where that leads that leads to the
worst place you can possibly imagine
and I know that like it I wouldn't even
think for me that it's an axiom of Faith
it's like no I know how totalitarian
States develop they develop when people
who have something to say
don't
speak
and I don't want to go there
I I I think I've lived that reality
having grown up I mean some of your
viewers may not know my personal history
having grown up in the Middle East
having gone through uh the early parts
of the Lebanese Civil War I always
contextualize any threats that I might
face in my job which of course are
serious
to what I faced when I grew up in
Lebanon and it's no surprise then that
many of the staunchest Defenders of
Western values end up being immigrants
like myself because we have we have
sampled from the wide Buffet of possible
societies and we know that the the
Western experiment is not it's an
outlier right it's it's an anomaly and
therefore it it typically takes people
who did not grow up in a western
tradition who've escaped the the hell
holes from which Davis great to then be
able to say hey westerners don't take
for granted the the freedoms that you
have uh and and and so if you look at
many of the you know think of Ayan
Hersey Ali right uh she can speak you
know with a lot of clarity and Authority
about uh some of these issues precisely
because she too has come from a similar
background to mine and so beyond me part
I want
Ian me park is another fantastic example
we've both had wonderful chats with her
and you know I don't know if you know
Yasmine Muhammad who who didn't grow up
do you know Yasmine Muhammad no no she
she wrote a book she I I think she grew
up in Canada but she had a very tough
upbringing where she was married to an
Islamic extremist who forced her to wear
the kneecub and so on and so I wonder
also if the fact that we come we meaning
myself and Ayan and yeah and so on we
come from these societies affords us a
bit more leeway when we speak than
someone like you because you know you're
the you know evil Western white male
whereas you know we're quote you know
brown people and so on and so we do have
high victimology scores so when and play
the the oppression Olympics against
those who might be coming after us
we can always cash in our chips because
as I've often joke but I'm being serious
that my my victimology poker card is
going to be higher than most people as
will yonmi Parks as well
whereas the fact that you don't have
that currency puts you at a distinct
disadvantage in the victimology poker
game right
the Bible is the root of all wisdom
inspiration and spiritual nourishment
the Hallow app empowers you to explore
the Bible's profound teachings and to
effortlessly incorporate them into your
daily life
a great place to start while you deepen
your understanding of the Bible is to
check out father Mike schmitz's Bible in
a year available on the Hello app for
brief daily readings and Reflections
here you can dive into an extensive
library of Bible reading plans
accompanied by insightful Reflections
and audio guided meditations whether
you're a seasoned Bible reader or just
starting your journey hallow provides a
platform for you to engage with
scripture like never before
studying the Bible's literary Brilliance
has influenced countless writers poets
and artists throughout history by
studying the Bible yourself you'll gain
a deeper appreciation for the power of
Storytelling symbolism and metaphor
enriching your understanding of
literature across different genres the
Hallow app also helps you connect with a
community of like-minded individuals
sharing experiences insights and
encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth download the app for
free at hallow.com Jordan you can set
reminders and track your progress along
the way enrich your education and
nurture your mind and soul today
download the Hallow app at hallow.com
Jordan that's hallow.com Jordan
hello.com Jordan for an exclusive
three-month free trial of all six
thousand plus prayers and meditations
right right well yeah so that might be
one level of defense that I that that I
don't have I don't have it yeah so okay
so let I want to delve a little bit more
deeply into your observations about your
conscience and I want to tie that into
our discussion of memes and parasitic
ideas okay and sure I want you to and
and I think
um for those of you who are watching and
listening God and I have had some
exchanges in the past with regards to
our somewhat differing opinions about
the utility of Union ideas about
archetypes and I want to segue into that
given this particular issue I think it's
a good entry point so
get I've been reading the uh biblical
Corpus in great detail in the last
months
um and and of course previous to that
because I'm writing a new book called we
who wrestle with God and one of the
things that I discovered in the analysis
of that sequence of stories was that
there was a transformation at the time
of Elijah which is what makes him a
canonical prophet
uh there was a con there was a
transformation in the conceptualization
of what constituted the highest
animating principle that the the
ultimate deity let's say yeah well in
this particular case from
and this occurred when Elijah stood up
against the prophets of Baal and the
prophets of Bal was a nature God and so
you could imagine among primordial
people and there's certainly Echoes of
this still within our own psyches that
extraordinarily
awe-inspiring natural events would
produce a kind of religious apprehension
so that could be earthquakes or typhoons
or
or uh tornadoes or thunderstorms
you know these these manifestations of
quasi-cosmic force that
can in some ways they definitely Inspire
awe and can bring you to your knees now
ball was a nature God
plain and simple and so what that meant
at that time was that
the highest authority to which people
owed fealty was the authority that made
itself manifest in the storm and in the
earthquake and in the Thunder now Elijah
had an intuition
um he was
uh what would you say uniquely isolated
follower of Yahweh at that time because
the Israelites the Israelite King had
married this woman named Jezebel and she
brought ball worship into the Israelite
society and attempted to obliterate the
worship of Yahweh as an Enterprise and
really reduce the ranks of the Yahweh
supporters to almost nothing to Elijah
you might even say now Elijah defeated
the
Priests of fall in a head-to-head
competition which I suppose was the
archaic equivalent of a debate but then
he had to run off because Jezebel got
wind of his victory and was going to
kill him and then he spent some time in
a cave and when he was in the cave
he experienced an earthquake and he
experienced a thunderstorm and some of
these magnificent magnificent displays
of nature but he had this intuition that
whatever the ultimate voice was was a
voice that spoke within and not
externally and so it's Elijah it's in
the book of Elijah that you find first
find the phrase the still Small Voice
Within essentially and so what happened
was there was a transformation of the
notion of the highest deity to something
that was external and a manifestation of
the grand
Grand uh what would you the grandiosity
of nature to this idea that no it was
something akin to the voice of
conscience Within
and so the reason I'm bringing that up
is because it's a radical psychological
transformation and a subtle one but I
also think I want to know what you think
you said that there are two things that
give you abiding that you have Abiding
Faith in
and one is the power of the word right
you're a professor you're a writer
you're a communicator you're a podcaster
and you are very careful in your
selection of words and and not only
so not only do you have faith in the
word let's say but you also believe that
you have uh the your highest moral
obligation is to be guided by your
conscience in the formulation of your
words okay so now you could think of
that and this is what this is where I
want to know your opinion
as far as I can tell one of the
meme-like qualities of the biblical
Corpus is the increasingly sophisticated
insistence as the stories unfold that
the highest animating principle is to be
understood not as a manifestation of the
awe-inspiring power of nature but it but
in terms of something that is relational
that's associated with the conscience
and that's tied to something like
adherence to this spoken and
communicated truth and so
and that that's become a very powerful
meme in the west right the dominant meme
you might say and so I'm I'm wondering
what you think about that like
especially given your your admission
let's say that the principle that does
animate your behavior for better or
worse is this Fidelity to the accuracy
of the of the word
right so I guess I mean there are
several ways that I can answer this one
of which is that I don't need to uh
situate my pathological and obsessive
defense of the truth in a supernatural
cause having said that though or in a
supernatural you know reason right
having said that though as an
evolutionist I'm fully aware that the
default value of human beings is
precisely to be uh moved by religion in
other words it in other words being a
non-believer is certainly not the
default value of humans that often
surprises people because they often
think that given that I'm not
particularly religious that somehow I
have a built-in animus towards religion
to the contrary I fully understand the
functional value of religion uh but and
I can I can concede that point without
necessarily believing that you know the
specific Supernatural elements are true
I can see that there is Great Value in
the Moral Stories and The Parables and
the allegories that are taught and so a
lot of the stuff that you might talk
about or a lot of the stuff that you
know the jungian archetypes I could
completely situate them within an
evolutionary Paradigm and fully agree
with them I think the the main place
where I might disagree with some of the
more religiously oriented folks is that
I stop at simply recognizing their
functional value without necessarily
believing in their veracity the action
right so okay okay so so okay so let me
ask you about that so let's take that
apart very carefully okay because you
you said that you can take the stance
that you've taken with no reference to
the supernatural all right so so let me
delve into that and you can help and
clarify my thinking on this in this
regard so okay so the first I'm going to
make some I'm going to offer some
propositions the first is is that
you're strangely and I I don't just mean
you I mean human beings in general but
also particularly you you're strangely
beholden to your conscience and in some
ways it operates as an autonomous entity
right because you know you know this
your conscience will call you on things
and you could say well my conscience is
me but then I would say well if it's you
why the hell don't you get the pesky
little thing under control and bend it
to your will instead of subordinating
yourself to its claims and and then I
would say it's claims because I think
that you can make a credible case that
the voice of conscience within you is
very much analogous to the voice of
conscience within me let's say but also
within all people and that in that
manner the person who does determine to
abide by their conscience is
conducting themselves in accordance with
something that if not Supernatural at
least has to be given status as
something Transcendent like
let me decorate that a little bit you
know perfectly well that when you're
thinking something through right when
you have a pressing question on your
mind that you'll get flashes of
intuition and I don't really think
there's a hell of a lot of difference
between intuition and Revelation
technically speaking right and it isn't
obvious at all where those flashes of
intuition come from and I think that if
you're a genuine scientist the voice of
Revelation within isn't really
distinguishable from that willingness to
pursue the truth and the willingness to
attend to the voice of conscience right
because you're supposed to be pursuing
the truth as a scientist and you make
you lay yourself open to so so can we
separate Transcendent and Supernatural
in some manner that's productive I'm not
sure that I'm able to answer the precise
question but what I can say is that
are conscious uh our morality is exactly
what you would predict
of a social species in a very material
way right because and I'm willing and as
a matter of fact many ethologists and
evolutionary scientists have already
made these arguments that there is a
very compelling scientific argument that
can explain the evolution of morality
without situating it within some
Transcendent you know uh religious
framework because many of the religious
folks will say yeah sure Evolution can
explain why we have opposable thumbs
Evolution can explain uh why there are
sex differences but it can never explain
morality and of course many
evolutionists some of whom are
incredibly accomplished thinkers have
argued that there's nothing uniquely
magical
about the construct of morality when you
have a social species the most the most
dangerous thing that you know humans
have faced our evolutionary history
other than Predators as our con
specifics as other people we're we're
walking through the Savannah and here
comes another group of folks that are
unrelated to us we don't know if they
are Friend or Foe and that's why one of
the reasons we've evolved coalitional
thinking right blue team versus red team
and so it makes perfect sense when you
have a non-solitary animal to evolve
things like a conscience things like the
emotions of anger retribution
vengefulness right so all of these
mechanisms whether it be morality or our
emotional system can be completely
couched in an evolutionary adaptive
framework but again that said
I think that it makes perfect sense for
an animal like us who's developed this
big prefrontal cortex who is regrettably
aware of their mortality to be uniquely
Intoxicated by religion because religion
offers us the ultimate pill for the most
fundamental problem which we face which
is the recognition of our mortality
right if I have high cholesterol level
and if we agree that let's say having
bad cholesterol is bad for you although
of course that's debated then I can go
see my physician he can give me a Statin
and my cholesterol scores will drop
unfortunately there is no pill for my
mortality fear other than the religious
solution right and so to me as a you
know as a functional analysis it makes
perfect sense for us to be susceptible
to believe in religion now I don't think
and here I'm gonna link up to I saw that
you've recently been having some spicy
exchanges with Richard Dawkins I don't
think I'm nearly as uh uh yeah I don't
exhibit as much animus towards religion
as does let's say Richard Dawkins again
I think because I'm coming from the
perspective that there are very clear
evolutionary reasons why we evolve to be
Believers and so
and oftentimes this uh assuages some of
the anger that the religious folks might
feel towards me because they actually
see that I don't have a built-in uh
hatred towards religion as a matter of
fact just as a side note it might
interest you to know that
there are two fundamental Ways by which
evolutionists can study religion there
is What's called the the adaptation
approach and the exactation approach so
maybe I could take a minute or two to to
address them the adaptation approach is
why would religion have ever evolved
what survival or mating Advantage would
be conferred on those who are religious
as opposed to those who are not
religious and the the the top argument
that's been proposed is one by David
Sloan Wilson The evolutionary biologist
who actually he wrote a great book
called Darwin's cathedral which if you
haven't read it Jordan I think you'd
enjoy it he uses a group selectionist
argument to argue that religious group
as compared to non-religious groups are
going to have greater likelihood of
surviving because religion affords you
greater cohesion communality cooperation
and so that's that would be one approach
to
situating an evolutionary understanding
of religion the exactation approach many
of your viewers may not be familiar with
that term an exactation is a byproduct
of evolution so for example if I say why
do humans have the color of the skeleton
that they have that itself was not
adaptive it's a byproduct of evolution
now the top guy for for the exactation
approach of religion is a evolutionary
Anthropologist named Pascal Boye who
basically argued that religion
piggybacks on neural systems that
evolved for other reasons and hence it's
a byproduct so so even if you are
someone who is not very religious but
you are grounded in evolutionary theory
you can fully understand why it is so
easy for most people to be religious
rather than wrong religious if that
makes any sense
this is real and happening now with the
abortion pill accounting for over half
of the abortions committed in the
country more than one thousand pre-born
children die at the hand of this Poison
every day preborn is the organization
providing the solution to this
devastating situation women are being
fed the abortion pill and led to believe
it's an easy out to terminate an
unwanted pregnancy but they are not
being told the truth about the harmful
side effects and the emotional trauma
left behind this is a heartbreaking
reality that needs to be addressed
pre-born Network clinics are there for
these women offering love hope and an
abortion reversal pill which can save
their baby if taken soon enough but they
cannot do this without our help as all
of their services are free for just 28
dollars you can help hurting women and
at-risk babies dial pound 250 and say
the key word baby or visit preborn.com
Jordan all gifts are tax deductible you
will never regret saving a child's life
that's pound 250 baby or visit
preborn.com Jordan
okay okay so so let me address a number
of the things that you just said the
first
the first comment I might want to make
and you you tell me what you think about
this God you know I don't think that
it's
unreasonable from a narrative
perspective
to frame you as someone possessed by the
same
spirit that made itself manifest in the
prophetic tradition
now this makes sense to me partly
because of your cultural heritage and
the way that you approach ideas but I
also think that it's true in a more than
merely passing sense
you know because one of the things that
you see that constantly characterizes
the prophetic tradition in the Old
Testament is that people like Jonah
so I just took the story of Jonah apart
for this book that I'm writing and so
it's very cool God so this is the
proposition in Jonah right Jonah is just
minding his own business
and
God makes himself manifest to Jonah in
the form of a call from conscience
that's the simplest way to think about
it and he tells Jonah
there's this city up near you called
Nineveh which is full of foreigners that
hate you and that that are your enemy
but they're deviating from the desirable
path and I'm thinking about wiping them
out
but um I think you should go up there
and say what you have to say on the off
chance they'll listen so that they tap
themselves back onto the straight narrow
and don't reap divine retribution and
Jonah being a very sensible person says
yeah I don't think I'll do that
um it doesn't sound like a great deal
for me it's me who's a foreign Jew
against 120 000 of my enemies why the
hell do you think they'll listen to me I
don't really care if they're saved
anyways how about I just go in the other
direction
so he rejects this call to speak right
now he's on a boat getting the hell out
of there eh and the sailors
um the storms come and the waves rise
and now the ship is in danger that's the
first hint in the story that
by refusing to speak when you're called
upon you put the ship itself in danger
that could be the ship of state right
now the sailors are kind of
superstitious and they think someone on
this boat is on outs with God or with
their gods we better find out who it is
so we can Rectify this situation so they
go interrogate all the passengers and uh
Jonah admits that he has defied a direct
order
and so he basically tells the sailors
who were somewhat loath to do this by
the way to throw him into the ocean
where he's going to drown and he might
think okay so what does that mean well
this is what it means to me is that if
you're called upon to speak and you stay
silent then you're going to put the ship
in danger and at par at the great Peril
of your own life
so now they throw him in the ocean you
think well that's about the worst thing
that could happen to poor Jonah because
now he's way the hell away from Shore
and he's going to drown that isn't the
worst thing that happens because the
next thing that happens is that some
horrible demon from the abyss itself
Rises up from the bottom of reality and
takes them in its jaws and pulls them
down to hell and I say hell because
that's how Jonah describes it and it's
also a type of the harrowing of hell
that is laid out in the gospel stories
much much later
and so this is my sense of what that
story means you know and and I think
this is something particularly relevant
to the experience of the Jews let's say
in the 20th century is that if you're
called upon to speak
and you reject that call not only do you
put the ship in danger and your life but
then you're going to be like what would
you say the jaws of Hell itself are
going to close around you and take you
to the bottom the very very bottom of
things
and I do think that's what happens to
States when the people in the states
don't speak so Jonah is down in hell
for three days in the belly of this
whale this Dragon whale and uh you know
he has a chance to think and he decides
well you know maybe I should have said
something when I was called upon to say
something and he repents and the whale
spits him out and then he goes to
Nineveh and he talks to all the
foreigners who are his enemies and they
actually listen and God decides not to
destroy them now you know that in that
story The Spirit of your ancestors and
mine
is portrayed as the voice that calls
from within to stand up and say what you
have to say even to those who would want
to destroy you even to those who have
habitually been your enemies and that if
you don't do that well you
you bring the forces of death and Hell
against yourself and everyone else and
so well there's see that's not exactly a
what would you say uh uh uh a testament
to the existence of the supernatural but
it is definitely The Testament to the
existence of something Transcendent that
you have
moral obligation to and so well so yes
yeah no I I I buy all of that and that
that's precisely why when people ask me
well how can you be so attached to your
religious identity and not be much of a
Believer it's precisely for the reasons
that you said which is I come from a
very long line of uh of thinkers uh
there are cultural values that come with
being Jewish that I'm very proud of uh I
don't know if you saw just on a slightly
uh a note of levity
have you seen Jordan the the Dutch AI
group that put together their best
rendition of what Jesus would look like
have you seen that image no no I haven't
where would I find that
well that image it turns out looks
hauntingly like the guy that you're
speaking to right now right and I mean
it's literally shocking so if you take
that image that the AI Dutch researchers
came up with and you take it now I'm not
I'm not engaging in in a delusion of
grandeur saying that I'm Jesus but what
I'm saying is that there is a lot to be
proud of in the Heritage that I come
from I'll tell you a quick story
personal story that speaks to that kind
of Jewish ethos
that I discussed in my last book in the
parasitic mind uh when I was talking
about uh you know the differences
between uh values of one culture and
another that which by the way speaks to
your point about personal responsibility
and so on so after I had finished uh so
I did a undergrad in mathematics at
computer science and then an MBA at
McGill I'm saying this not to flaunt my
CV because it's relevant to the story
and so after I had finished my MBA I my
goal was always to continue you know do
a PhD Behavioral Science and so on but
one of the places I've been accepted to
from my PhD was University of California
Irvine and my brother at the time lived
in Southern California he was a very
very successful entrepreneur and he was
trying to convince me having just
finished my MBA to take a couple of
years put on the proverbial suit work
with him a few years get some experience
and then of course go back and you know
pursue my PhD but I was really not
interested in that I always knew that I
wanted to be an academic
well when I returned home to Montreal
and my mother had caught wind of the
fact that my brother was trying to
convince me to stop my studies for a few
years she takes me to a side room she
says come I want to speak to you it
seemed like an ominous thing that she
wants to talk to me I said what's up Mom
she said well I hear that you're
thinking of not continuing with your PhD
and before I could even ass wash her
fears she said well do you want people
to know you as somebody who dropped out
of school so for her for the standards
of excellence of my family having a
degree in mathematics and computer
science and an MBA and then not going on
and doing your PhD would would bring
shame to the family would be a a
manifestation of having dropped out of
school now of course I didn't do my PhD
to to please my mother but it gives you
that's what you say
right you're speaking as the clinician
that you are right exactly and so right
and so and so that gives you a sense of
the importance that you know learning
has it's really a pathological desire
for uh that is instilled within you from
the youngest of age to be a learned
person and so I can be incredibly proud
of that Heritage because it is a real
material Heritage it's a real
sociological reality cultural reality to
be uh from that long tradition of Jews
again without necessarily buying into
every single element of the supernatural
so for example even if I were to concede
that God exists I can't imagine that the
ruler of the universe cares about
whether you light the Shabbat candles at
8 21 or 8 22 but I can promise you that
if you go to some of the Hasidic
neighborhoods in Montreal where they are
very Orthodox Jews they would argue that
no no God absolutely cares at the exact
minute when you so so in that sense
I could be very very much tied to my
religious Heritage without necessarily
caring about some of the ritualistic
elements okay so so I want to tell you
about a study that someone brought to my
attention about six months ago it's not
a very old study and
it's a really remarkable study and in
fact I think it's revolutionary so it
turns out you know that when when DNA
molecules are damaged they can repair
themselves and they generally do that
with spectacular accuracy but the
accuracy varies
okay so imagine this
imagine that there's a hierarchy of
genes
and that some genes are so fundamental
that if they vary even a trifle the
organism that they produce will be
non-viable
and then imagine that there are other
genes like the ones that code for eye
color where there can be tremendous
variability with virtually no
consequence now there might be minor
consequences like maybe maybe blue eyed
blondes have a sexual advantage over
those who aren't blue-eyed and blonde
you know because of attractiveness but
all but but having brown eyes or or
darker hair doesn't make you unviable
right now it turns out that there is a
relationship between the accuracy of DNA
repair mechanisms and the canonical
status of the genes that are being
repaired is the more fundamental the
gene is to the morphology upon which
existence itself depends the closer to
100 percent accuracy the repair
mechanisms manage
okay so so that means there's a core set
of genetic axioms you might say
that don't vary with mutation and
there's a peripheral set that are
allowed to vary you might say as
as experimental variations on the adapt
on the adaptational landscape
now I think there's an analog between
that and
conceptualizations let's say memes is
that there are some
Axiom some conceptual axioms that have
to remain utterly unchanged across time
and then there is a host of more
peripheral
propositions
that can vary substantively with
with no disadvantage and maybe some
Advantage because of the variability and
I think also that we regard the
canonical
axioms as deep and profound and were
affected if they move where we're
willing to abide or to allow and even to
enjoy variation on Fringe and so I'm
wondering you tell me what you think
about this with regard to what you
claimed is that you know you said that
you're unwilling to adhere to the more
Picayune distinctions that are made on
the religious front and some of those
might involve
right
the propositions of the existence of
something Supernatural
and inexplicable in its fundamental
nature
but but it also seems to me that for you
that's Allied
with an unshakable faith in certain
axiomatic presuppositions some of which
we already discussed which is like is it
incorrect for me to say that your
attachment to the communicated truth is
most appropriately
conceptualized as adherence to an
unshakable axiomatic Faith like I don't
understand how I don't understand how it
isn't so if you don't think it is then
help me understand and
right uh so so for example I now let's
bring in say my my math background in
mathematics there are axiomatic truths
right so take for example the
transitivity Axiom if I prefer car a to
car B and I prefer car B to car c it
must be that I prefer car a to car c if
I don't then that's called an
intransitive preference and therefore
I'm I'm committing a violation of
rationality those are actually dramatic
mathematical truths but they are also
empirical truths right if I throw a
person off a 100 store story building
100 times out of 100 I'll know exactly
what will happen because there's a thing
called gravity
so in other words I can pursue Truth uh
without and as you said universal truth
that is invariant to time or place and
those truths while we may couch them in
a supernatural cause I can completely
adhere to them without them being you
know
co-opted with a with a supernatural
element so for example in the parasitic
mind I hope we'll have a chance to talk
about my forthcoming book soon we can
actually talk about in the context of
religiosity and happiness if you'd like
that could be a good segue but uh in my
last book I in chapter seven I talk
about how to seek truth and I I offer
the epistemological approach called
nomological networks of cumulative
evidence uh and I think we have
discussed that privacy previously right
so the idea there is
that if I want to demonstrate to you
Jordan that there is a unshakable
universal truth what would be the data
that I would need to amass and present
to you for you to start coming around to
me and the way that you do that if
you're building a normal logical network
of humans of evidence is you come up
with data that
that is across cultures across eras
across species across methodologies
across theoretical Frameworks and if all
of these triangulate to demonstrate that
your phenomenon is universal then you're
well on your way to having built a
rather unassable unassailable argument
and so notice that I've been able to do
that without ever requiring some higher
Supernatural authority to contextualize
that truth and so again I'm very very uh
open to the idea that people need
religion I think it religion in in most
cases serves more benefits than than
costs although I wouldn't have left
Lebanon were it not for religion right
because it is specifically religious
hatred that caused me to leave Lebanon
right it wasn't
feasible in the mid 70s when the
Lebanese civil war broke out to be
Jewish in Lebanon because Lebanon is
exactly what happens to a society that
is completely organized along identity
politics lines so it's particularly
dismaying that the progressives and the
West wish to model that from which I
escaped in Lebanon but in that case the
reason why we had to leave Lebanon is
exactly due to religion because somehow
our religious Heritage was no longer
possible to to hold to practice in
Lebanon and we left so I I have an
ambivalent relationship with religion
all right so so let me ask you okay let
me ask you a couple things about that so
the first question might be
and this is something that we both
grappled with as academics
you know the universities have become
very corrupt
now you could argue on the one hand that
that corruption is just an extension of
the intellectual Enterprise as such
or you could argue that the corruption
that's made itself manifest in the
universities is a is a parasitical
extra Sense on the core
Enterprise the intellectual Enterprise
of the universities okay now on the
religious front the same issue emerges
right the question is is that when you
know you already pointed out earlier
that the parasitical Predator types can
utilize strategies of empathy let's say
to to amplify their attractiveness on
the sexual front right so they can co-op
something that emerged for other reasons
and bend it to their own purposes so is
it re so what do you think is more
reasonable like do you think that on the
religious front that the danger you're
exposed to in Lebanon is a merely a
consequence of the fact that the
religious Enterprise itself is flawed
and will produce this multiplicity of
competing and often murderously
competing claims or is it reasonable to
assume that something analogous happens
on the religious front and that the
fundamental conflict is a consequence of
the predatory parasites twisting uh
fundamentally axiomatic and necessary
religious claims to their own devices
and and sewing Discord as a consequence
well I can't be so charitable as to give
religion a a free pass because many of
the religious narratives certainly in
the abrahamic faiths are precisely US
versus them right so so there is no way
to misinterpret some of the teachings in
many of these books whether it be
Deuteronomy so the old Old Testament
whether it be in certain Christian
doctrines and certainly when it comes to
Islamic doctrines it is very difficult
to quote misread or mistranslate and
it's certainly difficult to tell someone
who's who Arabic Arabic is their mother
tongue that I'm misunderstanding what is
being communicated let's say in some
elements of you know the Islamic faith
my point here is not to uniquely bash
Islam because as I said all abrahamic
faiths have a US versus them mentality
so I think what happened in Lebanon is
not some human co-opting of otherwise
benign and loving religious narratives
uh let's put it another way and again
this you may not like because I'm boring
from Richard Dawkins and I know that
you've been having a little tiff with
him Richard Dawkins famously said that
the difference between an atheist and a
very staunch believer is really very
minimal if we assume that there are 10
10 000 Gods the very religious person is
an atheist on
999 Gods but is very fervently a
believer in one whereas The non-believer
Atheist is a non-believer on Ten
Thousand so there's only a difference of
999 to ten thousand that strikes me as a
pretty compelling argument let me put it
another way in the consuming instinct
which was one of my earlier books in
2011 I had a whole chapter where I was
talking about the thought experiment of
what might happen if an extraterrestrial
uh being came to Earth shopping for the
one good faith and what I did there I
mean some people might think that I was
you know being facetious but actually I
was being deadly serious I said take
every single issue that you could think
of from the most consequential to the
most banal and I can find you two
religions that purport the exact
opposite prescription
does God want you to eat prosciutto yes
if you're Catholic absolutely know if
you're Jewish or Muslim what's God's
view on homosexuality I can give you
some that are totally okay with it some
that are not I mean literally I give a
million so how can you then argue for a
specific religion when on any given
point I can find two religions that are
perfectly contradictory okay okay okay
so I I think I have an answer to that
that you might find at least interesting
so I forgot that in your book you laid
out the rationale for normal logical
networks let me just develop that a
little bit and this is from your new
book okay so the idea of a normal
logical network is akin to the idea of
sensory
quintangulation let's call it that and
so everyone knows that we have five
senses
now each of those senses uses a
qualitatively different strategy of
measurement
right somewhat independently evolved and
so and so our
proposition as embodied biological
organisms is that if something manifests
itself simultaneously
in the domains covered by the five
dimensions of our senses it's real right
so what's real you can taste it you can
touch it you can see it you can hear it
you can feel it if if you can do all
five of those then there's a pretty damn
good chance that it's real
now
actually that turned out not to be real
enough
and that's partly why
the development of language
had some adaptive utility because
because you and I can communicate
I can use your five senses transmitted
to me through the linguistic domain to
calibrate my five senses and then we can
do that on Moss and to a large degree
that's what science does
all right so you take multiple
independent sources of measurement and
if they converge then you assume that
there's something there
fair enough so far yeah I'm with you
okay okay I would say from from from
what I've been able to understand that
that's what the unions did in their
archetypal analysis now you can debate
as the postmodernists have about whether
or not what they found was spurious but
in my maps of meaning book what I tried
to do was to take what the unions had
discovered by constructing a normal
logical network of cross-cultural
mythological analysis and I tried to
beat that against the measurement
techniques of Behavioral Psychology and
Neuroscience and I found at least I
claimed in that book to have found like
a substantive non-trivial and surprising
degree of overlap so so let me and I
think this is relevant to your book on
happiness now you tell me what you think
about this because happiness doesn't
just mean transitory hedonic joy and you
certainly don't think that because that
isn't how you live
so the the core element of the hero
archetype is the injunction that you
should Advance courageously in the face
of threat if said threat stands as an
obstacle between you and a valid goal
yes right right and so that's different
than rabbit mythology which would be
when you see a wolf freeze
the human myth is no no when you
encounter a threat
you explore it until you master it okay
and as far as I can tell all the
variants of hero mythology are basically
that right it's the dragon fight is that
you find the terrible predator and
that's what a dragon is it's an emblem
of of the predator and you encounter
that voluntarily and as a consequence
you get the Virgin so that's on the
sexual front and you get the gold and
that's on the material front
and so and you know the unions to their
credit and I really do think to their
credit pointed out that that
underlying narrative structure makes
itself manifest cross-culturally and a
multitude of forms now unfortunately to
understand that you have to throw
yourself pretty deeply into that body of
research right and it's pretty arcane
and and young thoughts symbolically and
so he's
he's not a particularly
he's not a thinker who's particularly
amenable to people whose primary mode of
thought is rational rather than pattern
recognition
right right right so but but like I do
think the unions used a normal logical
Network and I think that the core
religious doctrine that they converged
on was something like the universal
validity of the hero myth and the
Redemptive quality of that courageous
advancement in the face of the unknown
and so that that's a place where you
could because your question was well
there's all these competing religious
claims right and I'd say well there's no
way I can
offer a contrary perspective to that
Viewpoint given the multitude of
contradictory religious claims but then
I would say there's a hierarchy of
claims and some of them are more Central
and there is a convergence at the level
of what claims are most Central and I
think the convergence is analogous to
your proposition that you should abide
by the truth in your communicative in
your exploration and your communicative
Enterprise and I think that's associated
with the kind of happiness that you're
writing about in your new book right a
kind of deep happiness
right uh I mean I agree largely with all
that you've said about the the universal
myths that the jungians talk about and
again there have been many studies from
an evolutionary perspective that look
for example like if I want to study
female sexuality the best way to study
it is to do a archetypal analysis of the
male hero in romance novels and it turns
out that the male hero in romance novels
is the exact same guy in every single
romance novel that has ever been written
I mean to the point that you would think
it's been plagiarized he is tall
to my detriment since I'm not tall uh he
he wrestles alligators on his six-pack
and wins he is a surgeon and a prince uh
he's reckless in his behavior but he can
only be tamed by the love of of one
woman right and so I just described
everything Beauty and the Beast yep
and so these archetypal narratives are
Universal precisely because they are an
indelible part of human nature and that
manifestation exists independently of
whether you believe in the Supernatural
origin of those stories or not but if I
can just quickly segue into my
forthcoming book so I do talk about
religiosity and happiness in my
forthcoming book and you and many other
folks who are who you know are very
pro-religion will be happy to know that
the research shows and I know that you
probably know this that there is a
moderate correlation between religiosity
and happiness meaning that on average
uh people who are more religious tend to
manifest higher happiness scores but we
can discuss why that is now I argue that
that doesn't mean though that if you're
not religious you can't find your way to
mount happiness uh and I can couch it in
a Divine language so you and I are right
now engaging in an intoxicating
conversation that is truly Divine Right
friendships are Divine as Aristotle said
and as I described in my book The the
love that you have for your children and
your wife is a form of you know Divine
love uh having purpose and meaning in
your chosen profession I talk about that
in the book I basically argue that the
two most important decisions that either
make you happy or incredibly miserable
is choosing the right spouse and
choosing the right profession if you
make those two choices correctly you're
well on your way to being a happy that
was Freud's observation right work and
love that was his
and look and he said it a hundred years
ago and I've said it today precisely
because they are Universal truths to our
earlier point you know one of the things
that I did in this book is really delve
into the you know the ancient Greeks you
know Epictetus and and the Seneca and
Marcus Aurelius and here I want to point
to a quip that my
fellow Lebanese friend Nassim Talib once
told me which turns out to be uh
hauntingly true he he once was teasing
me that he said I don't know what you
study in Psychology God because
everything that there is to know about
human nature the ancient Greeks have
already said and now he was he was
quipping me he was teasing me uh but as
I started delving into that literature I
said I think Nassim might be right
because I would get some I would get
some insight
for example about the link between
cognitive behavior therapy and some some
other you know mechanism of you know
happiness and so on and then I find out
that Epictetus had made that exact point
over 2 000 years ago so so I think that
there are these Universal truths that
exist whether it is and how we seek
happiness or in in any other domain of
human import that are Universal
precisely because they are an indelible
part of our human nature I mean that's
why I love evolutionary psychology so
much because it is very difficult to
have powerful explanations of human
behavior void of an evolutionary
understanding of our species and so it
always amazes me that people exhibit an
animus to evolutionary psychology what
else could it be like where did your
brain come from if you take it outside
of the purview of evolutionary theory so
one of the things that I talk about in
the book that speaks to your very kind
introduction at the start where you
talked about me having a sense of humor
I have a whole chapter on I call it life
as a playground and I basically argue
that even the most serious Pursuits for
example the pursuit of science
is a form of Play It's the highest form
of play right because in the same way
that you try to solve a 1 000 piece
puzzle by putting the pieces together
well what is science it's it's drawing
links between a whole bunch of variables
that heretofore you didn't know were
linked together so the whole Endeavor of
science is a form of or geostic higher
order play right yeah and so if it's
done right
if it's done right and and so that's by
the way one of the reasons why you know
I have the sense of humor that I have is
because I think it's a very very
powerful way to communicate very serious
things some people will say oh but
aren't you a basing yourself as a
serious Professor by donning that pink
wig or by self-flagellating because
you're mocking that you're friends with
Jordan Peterson no because mockery is
actually a astronomically powerful way
to demonstrate certain forms of lunacy
right that's why uh dictators will
usually try to eradicate the satiris
first they don't go after the guys with
the big muscles they go after the guys
with the sharp tongues and the stinging
pen because those are the ones that are
the biggest threat and so so you might
be interested in this so I spent a lot
of time studying Jacques Bank steps work
on play and he he detailed out the
neurophysiology of play to a greater
degree than any other scientist that I
know and
hanksept conceptualized play
in really I would say is the highest as
the state of highest possible neural
integration
because
play only emerges when all competing
motivating and emotional systems have
been uh
satiated and and put aside so if you're
able to enter into a state of play
that's actually an indication that
you've mastered the domain in which
you're exploring so thoroughly that no
other competing motivations whatsoever
can emerge to disrupt that you know and
laughter
eradicates muscular tension when I used
to work out with my friends we used to
make jokes when people were bench
pressing and as soon as they laugh there
must they couldn't hold the weight
anymore which was a good part of the
joke but you know I I've spent a lot of
time in my last tour laying out the idea
to my audiences that the antithesis of
tyranny is playing like if you had
tyranny is a spirit of sorts right it's
a malevolent spirit and you might say
well what the hell's the opposite of
that and I don't think it's joy and I
don't think it's like the absence of
fear or pain I think it's literally play
and so I think you're dead on in that in
the allying of the spirit of play with
the highest form of Happiness it's
really something to aim for
at your exact exactly right and actually
so to link play with our earlier
discussion about you know choosing the
right spouse uh so as you as you know
Jordan you know one of the fundamental
rules Universal rules for a happy
marriage is the birds of a feather flock
together Maxim so they are sort of two
competing ideas Opposites Attract versus
birds of a feather flock together now if
you're interested in a short-term sexual
values then opposites attracts might
perfectly might work perfectly well yeah
I may be introvert you're extrovert you
might bring me out of my you know sexual
shyness but that's for a short-term uh
you know uh Valiants but for sure for
long-term relationships
it is birds of a feather flock together
at least on things like life goals
values belief systems it's not at all
Opposites Attract now that principle of
birds of a feather flock together
applies specifically
to playfulness and there's very very
interesting research which uh if you're
not familiar with I I'd be happy to send
you some links that looks at how uh
people who assort on their adult
playfulness scores tend to have happier
marriages and I give seven oh I'd like
examples yeah I'd like to see that yeah
I'll be I'll be happy to send you that
okay and so for example one of the
things that makes I mean I know you've
met my wife a few times and you know
that we have a very strong relationship
we've been together for 23 years is that
we're constantly in play mode right she
can rib on me and so you know so for
example I'll walk into the room you know
I'll you know engage in some kind of
full grandiosity showing off my muscles
and then she'll say something like oh we
might need to fortify the the the the
base of this house because I don't think
your ego fits in this house anymore
right so that's a very fun right and
we're constantly engaging in this kind
of play we're very very good friends
with each other now of course you can't
always predict a priori when you're
choosing to marry someone whether you
you score perfectly compatibly on all of
these things but trying to find someone
who shares your life mindsets is
certainly a prescription uh for leading
a happy marriage and I'm right I'm
willing to play together maybe that's
why teeth was made out of Adam's Rib
perhaps there you go Bringing In the
religious narrative wonderful some of
the other things that I talk about is I
talk about
um uh so I I argue that the most
fundamental universal law that is most
ubiquitous is something that Aristotle
had already talked about in his uh
nicomachian ethics book uh the golden
mean right too little of something is
not good too much of something is not
good and The Sweet Spot lies somewhere
in the middle right which mathematically
is referred to as the inverted U right
somewhere in the middle is the time and
I demonstrate in one of the chapters
that whether it be at the neuronal level
the individual level the uh this
economic level the societal level
the same pattern of the inverted U
manifests itself across countless
domains so for example how much alcohol
should you consume that follows an
inverted you how much fish should you
consume that falls in inverted you how
intense your exercise should be that
follows an inverted you and on and on
and on so the challenge is to try to
find where your sweet spot is and if you
can find that you're well on your way to
happiness another thing that I talk
about in the book is how to assuage the
threats of regret at the end of your
life so and here I talk about uh my
former professor of psychology at
Cornell Thomas gilovich who's a pioneer
of regret theory he argued that there
are two sources of regret regret due to
actions and regret due to inactions so I
regret that I cheated on my wife and now
my marriage is over that's a regret due
to action versus regret due to inaction
is I always wanted to be a artist but I
became a pediatrician because my dad was
a pediatrician and it turns out that
people's most looming regret are those
of inaction right the what if I wish I
would have done and so do you think do
you think that's the same thing that
befalls people when they hold their
tongue when they have something to say
because that's a form of inaction that
that could easily resistance isn't that
same thing that's exactly right exactly
right and that's why by the way to use
my earlier argument about when I put my
head on the pillow and I need to feel
that I didn't walk away from defending
the truth I I would be regretful if I
did that if I held my tongue and did not
weigh in on Twitter to some inane BS
that someone then I would be very
regretful and therefore I live a life
some might argue of obsessive
authenticity and I say obsessive because
sometimes I'm authentic to a fault I
can't hold my tongue if it means that
I'm doing it for careerist reasons
because then I feel as though I'm being
inauthentic right and so but that makes
me happy because then my personhood has
no fissures I don't feel like a fraud I
feel real and for better or worse then I
present myself to the world with full
confidence and happiness
we are just days away from the Durban
Accords the greatest threat to the US
Dollar's Global dominance in the past 80
years on August 22nd brics Nations
Brazil Russia India China and South
Africa are expected to announce the
launch of a new international super
currency fully backed by gold or other
Commodities you can protect your IRA or
401K from The Fallout of this Landmark
Announcement by diversifying with gold
from Birch gold historically gold has
been a safe haven in times of high
uncertainty which is right now how much
more time does the Dollar have protect
your savings with gold Birch gold has an
A plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau and thousands of happy customers
text Jordan to 989898 and get your free
info kit on gold again text Jordan to 98
thank you
um you're very active on Twitter I don't
know if you're as active as I am on
Twitter but we have a pretty it's it's
it's a close battle and I think our
style of interaction on Twitter is
analogous so I have a couple of
questions for you there it's like
how do you protect yourself against
using your what would you say your
charismatic forthrightness that's a good
way of thinking about it how do you
protect yourself against using that
egotistically and for instrumental gain
I mean you have a wife that pokes fun at
you and that's helpful but and how do
you know you're doing that and how do
you know when you're poking and prodding
to be authentic that you're not
you know you're not mouthing off and
going too far and showing off and and
and you know engaging in an ego display
on that front how how do you
do you think you always keep yourself in
check and how do you do it if you do it
successful that's that's an amazing
question because I've struggled with
that conundrum when two important values
Within Me conflict with one another so
on the one so let me give you an example
uh
I may have a good friend who's spouting
nonsense on Twitter okay and because of
my values maybe my middle eastern values
you know you don't go after a friend so
I'll hold my tongue for a while but then
I start there's that voice in my head
that says but wait a minute if you hold
your voice and don't correct that person
if you think that they are uttering
gibberish then you're being inauthentic
that's exactly what happened not that I
wish to bring him back to the Forefront
but that's what happened between Sam
Harris and me because we were on very
friendly terms we got along very very
well we we've gone out to dinner I'd
been on his show and for about four or
five years I kept completely quiet about
his you know Trump hysteria because I
felt that I I owed him because I knew
him I had to have kind of a higher
standard of restraint but then at one
point I felt that my being
restraining in my interactions with him
I was being inauthentic to the truth and
therefore I went after him and and I
thought was a playful way but he didn't
take well to it and regrettably I guess
I presume that we're no longer friends
now which is a real shame and so I
struggle with that exact issue but I
think the fact that I struggle with it
is itself a form of ultimate humility
right because if I didn't struggle with
it if I was always self-assured in
everything that I did without having the
back voice in my head telling me are you
doing the right thing then I would never
engage in these Auto corrective
behaviors so I don't have a definitive
answer I I do struggle with that issue
is it always best to tell the truth or
should you hold your tongue once in a
while it's a tough one to navigate well
how much do you think how much of a rule
do you think the social connections that
you have play in helping regulate your
behavior like you have a good
relationship with your wife like are
there are the people in your family the
people that you're close to are they
keeping an eye on you and giving you a
whack when they think that you've
stepped out of line
well certainly my wife is very good at
doing that because in her case she sees
the fact that I might get angry at some
insane thing that's being said at
Twitter on Twitter and then she'll kind
of come in because she'll see me like
having you know kind of shaking my head
on my laptop she says okay what are you
upset at now who said what and then
she'll try to kind of come in and say
why don't we go out for a walk or why
don't we play with our children and so
that's another thing that makes choosing
the right spouse so important because
they react they recognize your
behavioral traps they recognize where
you might falter and they make you a
better person and I I hope I also offer
that to her and so right right turns out
to be a beautiful symbiotic relationship
yeah I see I learned from how you
interact with your wife uh you you share
a similar love of your wife yeah you
know and I think we like we used to play
together as kids say like we were
childhood friends and that's true yeah
yeah yeah and and you know what's really
been interesting Gad and this is really
a form of Miracle as far as I'm
concerned and I I think it's because
both of us passed so close to death in
the last few years I mean Tammy almost
died every day for about eight months it
was really quite awful and I was out of
commission for two and a half years you
know when we when we came back together
we were pretty alienated from one
another because I really hadn't been
around for two years and she had been
recovering from her terrible illness and
to some degree in isolation and you know
we'd diver our Pathways had diverged to
some degree and I was still quite sick
when I came back home you know and what
saved us was the habit of play that we
had established over decades you know
and we came together again
in the field of play and that reunited
us very quickly and the thing that's
been so miraculous about this and it it
really has been a staggering
Revelation to me is that
that Spirit of play has magnified itself
now to such a degree that when I'm with
her and we're in a playful mood I can
see her across in some ways I can
perceive her across the whole span of
the time that we spent together right
from you know 1969 to now and it's like
I'm playing with that person that I've
always known you know and that's
actually deepened as we've
got to know each other over the decades
that's got more and more profound and
and also more and more like a return to
the state of mind that we had when we
were young kids eight years old you know
playing together as as as friends and
that's really it's an amazing thing it's
it's it's certainly one of the best
things that's that's ever happened to me
in my whole life
so you know and and Eve the word Eve I
learned this from Ben Shapiro the word
eve means beneficial adversary right it
means something like Optimal partner in
play
that's fine oh I didn't know that either
yeah he's not cool that's so cool
that is very very cool uh yeah so so the
you know one of the things one of the
reasons why I wrote this book I never
thought that I would write a happiness
book I thought that Jordan Peterson had
already uh occupied that Niche but the
reason why I wrote the book is because a
lot of people would write to me and say
how is it that you always are able to
present yourself to the world as happy
and and there and of course about 50 of
your happiness comes from your genes
that can't be controlled some of us have
a sunny dispositions some of us have a
more uh gloomy disposition and that's
fine but the good news is that there's
still 50 up for grabs right so even if
50 of your Genesis come of your
happiness coming from your genes there
is another 50 that the choices that you
make the the mindsets that you adopt
that can either increase the likelihood
of happiness or decrease it and so I
thought you know what I'd never thought
about the idea of writing a book of
happiness but tons of people are
approaching me with you know asking
soliciting advice why don't I take a
shot at it and that's what led to my
latest book well you know maybe to to
tie this back to the way that we opened
our conversation you know maybe one of
the reasons too that has protected you
to some degree against being pilloried
too extensively except in those serious
cases that we discussed is the fact that
you've been markedly good at maintaining
that playful men through all of your
interactions right and that you are
willing to put yourself forward you know
on a fairly
on a fairly regular basis even in in
absurdist guys with your fright wig and
your self-flagellation whip and and so
you know I think that good humor has
also been a really good it's not a
defensive Shield you know because that
that that's like something you're hiding
behind you're not hiding and it takes
humility right and it takes right to
bring self-confidence right because
someone could look at that and say my
God this guy is looking like a buffoon
and so it takes a lot of courage to your
earlier point to be able to put yourself
in that position right I remember the
one of the first times that I I know
we've both been on Jordan on uh Joe
Rogan's show many times one of the
nicest compliments that he gave me he
said you know you're you're really cool
because you're not like many other
professors who take themselves too
seriously right so so I can be austere
and professorial when I need to be when
I'm speaking at Stanford and I could be
a complete Joker when the occasion
demands it and so and and one doesn't
diminish from the other you can both be
a serious person and an incredibly
playful person that's certainly a path
to happiness oh yeah yeah you bet that
that's an optimized path to happiness
right look that's a really good place to
stop and so your book is coming out in
Late July that's the sad truth about
happiness you said it comes out on July
25th and so those of you out there who
are pouting away miserably and
wretchedly might want to go pick up that
book and see if you can pick up a tip or
two and
um also you know as we discussed God
wrote parasitic mind and that's
definitely a book worth picking up if
you haven't done that already so you
could you know buy both what the hell
you know and then you can free him from
the terrible shackles of the Communists
at Concordia University of your lips the
God's ear
no kidding eh so look thank you very
much for talking to me today it's always
a pleasure to talk with you I hope we
see each other in Montreal in person at
some not too distant point in the future
that seems highly probable
um for those of you watching and
listening on YouTube thank you very much
for your time and attention
um I hope you appreciated the
conversation as I did
um to the Daily wire plus folks for
facilitating this conversation now it's
much appreciated film crew here in
Toronto that's appreciated as well
um I'm gonna take God over to the dark
side the daily wire plus side uh behind
the paywall
um and we're going to talk about
um more autobiographical and personal
issues I would say that's generally the
tenor there and so if you want to join
us there uh uh please please feel
welcome and invited we certainly
appreciate your patronage and otherwise
Gad thank you very much for talking to
me today
thank you sir cheers yeah and good luck
with the launch your book man I I hope
that you you rip up the best seller
charts and that the New York Times is
forced to put you in its list
thank you so much Jordan such a pleasure
to talk to you and uh please stay in
touch I might be coming down to Florida
at some point soon are you going to be
in Florida anytime soon
um are you coming down to do some
lectures for Peterson Academy
I am the only decision is whether it's
going to be in Toronto or Florida I'm
discussing it with your people so that's
on the roster I think for August so what
are you gonna let what are you going to
lecture on
well so that's the thing uh of course it
could be the happiness book uh or
evolutionary psychology or the
prosthetic mind my my penchant is to go
with the happiness stuff if only to time
it with the current book but we'll see
I'm I'm opening well you could do three
sets of lectures and then you wouldn't
have to be sure yeah that would be good
okay well look hopefully we'll see you
there or we'll see you in Montreal or
we'll see you in Toronto and thank you
Jordan thank you Batman you bet talk to
you soon bye-bye bye bye bye bye
[Music]
thank you